Heiz aber fair heute meldete Voca Wahnsinn wird
die Wärmepumpe zur peniskanone für die AFD [Musik]
die Regierung will den Bürgern
grüne teuer Energie aufzwingen
und treibt sich so in die Arme der
AFD warum wir haben als Experten den
ältesten weißen Mann verpflichtet den
wir finden konnten herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
hallo seit wann diskutieren jetzt im Fernsehen
das ist doch nicht normal auch ich bin überrascht
ich dachte es sei normal hier wenigstens
das deutsche Idiom beherrschen zu können
ja deswegen frage ich mich ja warum sie hier
sind weil das heißt Idiot und nicht Idiot Herr
Albaner sie sind bundesweit bekannt geworden
als Kämpfer gegen die heizungspolitik der Ampel
und Wärmepumpen das wird nicht funktionieren
die Leute würden im Winter erfrieren mit
dieser Politik meine Damen und Herren
ist zufällig ein Dolmetscher anwesend
zugegeben ich habe kaum ein Wort verstanden
aber ich bin mir sicher es war Klartext wir
müssen die Dinge beim Normen nennen und ich sage
es gern auch noch einmal für alle unnormalen hapex
heizungsgesetz für dazu dass die Münchner
erfrieren ein Horror-Szenario einerseits
andererseits sind die Großstädter jetzt nicht
gerade ihre Stammwähler ja warum sollten die
Grünen ihre Wähler umbringen ja ich habe es doch
schon in Erding gesagt das stimmt schauen wir mal
sie wollen nicht das Klima retten sondern
sie wollen in Deutschland kaputt machen
und sie fangen mit den eigenen WLAN an jetzt
sie töten uns mit dem Heizraum Oma bekannt
der ist eine Atombombe für dieses Land sagt
die Bild das heißt also Putin droht in der
Ukraine mit dem Einsatz seiner Wärmepumpe
ja das ist eine motzenvernichtungswaffe
unsere Mieten werden explodieren der
heilsamer sprengt den Sozialstaat
seltsam in Norwegen heizen bereits 60% damit
Gottes Willen das muss ja furchtbar das muss
gibt es beim Griechen wollen sie damit
sorgen dass die Bild-Zeitung übertreibt
die bildchefredakteurin hat doch erklärt warum
die Bild-Zeitung so über die Wärmepumpe berichtet
hat ich darf auch mal hier wir haben hier verdammt
noch mal niemanden der weiß wie so eine Wärmepumpe
funktioniert verstehen sie das sagt sie nach
monatelanger Hitze über eine angebliche Atombombe
Fakten freie Debatten sind deine Gefahr für die
Demokratie aber wer eine Pflicht für Fakten Treue
nicht eine Gefahr für die Pressefreiheit aber es
reicht doch wenn der Ministerpräsident Bescheid
weiß stimmt Markus würde gemeint auf Twitter der
heilsamer muss gestoppt werden die Wärmepumpe
zerstört den Traum vom Eigenheim und kostet bis zu
300.000 Euro man bekommt eine Wärmepumpe schon ab
15000 € sie wollen behaupten der Ministerpräsident
lügt wieso die Zahl 300000xistiert und nicht in
diesem Zusammenhang die Wärmepumpenhersteller
meinen da ist eine Null zu viel willkommen
Schatzi bitte bitte [Applaus]
außerdem muss man das ganze Haus
isolieren oder läppern sich die
Nullen das müssen Sie nicht die Wärmepumpe
funktioniert wie jede andere Heizung auch
ohne Isolierung nur schmeißt sie das Geld
dann halt zum Fenster raus ja jetzt sagen
Sie es ja selbst rausgeschmissen es geht
warten sie ich muss mich kurz isolieren
mir lassen uns nicht von der grünen dominanten
Ampel vorschreiben wie wir zu heizen haben
manche Wissenschaftler die meinen wir müssten die
CO2 Emissionen auch bei den Heizungen drastisch
reduzieren reagiert habe also womöglich angemessen
auf die Klimakrise also ich habe manchmal das
Gefühl die Natur steckt mit dem grünen unter
einer Decke bitte finden Sie es nicht auffällig
wie sich die Forderungen der beiden Engel Herr
Newton würden Sie sagen die Natur neigt mit ihrem
Gesetzen dazu die Menschen zu denken natürlich
Natur sitzt nie auf Freiwilligkeit und Einsicht
in diese Ressourcen sind knapp gerade in Bayern
wir lieben die Natur ja so lang sie unsere Heimat
ist und uns mit Abschnitte von bayerischen Viertel
zack Schnitzeln von bayerischen Wälder beliefert
kann es sein dass ihre Heimat am
liebsten auffressen und verfeuern
das ist wahre Heimat liebe sie haben
aber schon mitbekommen dass ich der
Zustand der bayerischen Waldbäume stark
verschlechtert ein Viertel ist bereits
stark geschädigt er sorgt so was über
unseren Land die bayerische sturzregierung
finden Sie [Applaus]
finden Sie das eine vertrauenswürdige
Quelle ja das sind auf jeden Fall gut
hin Nachrichten weil das bedeutet ja dass
wir genügend Brennholz haben ja weil wir
verheizen ja nur das was von selbst umfällt
aber in ganz Europa werden Wälder für Pellets
abgeholzt die Hälfte der EU Holzernte wird
verbrannt er die EU ist ja nicht meine Heimat
außerdem produziert Holz bei der
Verbrennung mehr CO2 Emissionen
als Kohle und Gas du bist ja nachhaltig in
80 Jahren das ist doch für sie kein Alter
sie sagen in Erding sie wollen die
Demokratie zurückholen das hieße ja
wir leben jetzt in einer heizdiktatur das wäre
ja furchtbar und sie werden quasi Vize Diktator
in Bayern her Demokratie weil da noch die normalen
an der Regierung sind ich lasse mich von ihnen
nicht in die rechte Ecke drängen ich vertrete
die Mehrheit der Mitte und die Mitte kann nicht
gerecht sein aber sie ist gegen das salzgesetz das
stimmt 80 % der Bundesbürger lehnt das Verbot von
Gas und Ölheizungen ab aber gleichzeitig war eine
deutliche Mehrheit von weit über 50% für habe ich
Zeit gesetzt das stimmt auch das stimmt denn nun
ihre Mehrheit ist gespalten ja sie will dass wir
mit erneuerbaren Energien heizen aber gleichzeitig
an Öl und Gas festhalten und es ist genau meine
Linie aber wie wollen Sie daraus Politik machen ja
das will er ja gar nicht er will ein Kulturkampf
führen also doch gegen möchte ich mich auf
schärfste waren ja mit Kunst und Literatur
habe ich nichts am Hut Kulturkampf ist keine
elitäre Sache da kann jeder mitmachen da geht
zum ihr Fleisch und ihr Auto und das ist sagen das
lassen wir uns doch nicht wegnehmen auch wenn in
das gar niemand wegnehmen will ja genau das ist
ja die kulturelle Leistung da schauen Sie wir
wollen doch einfach das schützen was die Mehrheit
will die Mehrheit will auch ein Tempolimit und
eine Vermögenssteuer ja wir vertreten ja nur
die normale Mehrheiten und woran erkennt man
die die Leben auf dem Land und will mich aber
die Freien Wähler haben doch nur zehn Prozent
oder sehen Sie mal wie die normalen unterdrückt
werden ein sehr schönes Schlusswort ja schön
sie haben doch noch gar nicht gesagt das ist gar
keine klimaneutrale Alternative zur Wärmepumpe
gibt dieser ganze zinober wurde doch nur
veranstaltet damit Gasheizungen möglichst lange
im Betrieb sind ein riesige Kampagne der Fossil
Lobby und wer hat das Gebäude Energie gesetzt
jetzt mit einer Klage beim Verfassungsgericht
gestoppt der CDU Abgeordnete der Heilmann der ein
Vermögen mit Gas gemacht hat genau und das alles
können Sie morgen in unserem Faktencheck nicht
nachlesen denn hier bei TV normal geht es nicht um
die Fakten der anderen sondern um unsere Gefühle
dann war das hier alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug